way back in december of 2017 i set the
world record for the fastest speed kill
of a gold lynel with a combination of
different combat techniques
now with new advancements and
discoveries being found the most
advanced and efficient combat technique
for decimating lynels
is
you couldn't make this up if you tried
an actual speed killing technique in
breath of the wild
requires you to steer your controller
back and forth like your six-year-old
nephew at a racing arcade machine
now let's explain how and why this works
and of course if you like short
explainer videos such as this
let us know with a like players have
long known the best mounted only combat
technique in the game called permanent
active hitbox
it's a nifty technique where it allows
link while mounted to have a weapons
hitbox
always do damage even when you're not
actively swinging it
by first swinging the weapon once
holding jump then
canceling the jump with the b button
link will sit back down and the weapon
will still actively be able to do damage
this can be done with any weapon and
sets up for some really cool
possibilities
including infinite elemental effects and
switching the hitbox's position
such as holding attack putting it on
your back
or even readying a throw this is where
the damage possibility comes from
because now you have physical control
over the weapon's position
using motion controls giving you a
higher attack speed than sometimes even
spinning the weapon
this in a sense is just an extremely
janky but powerful version of what you
see in skyward sword with control over
the weapon's position
now how do we up the damage to take
advantage of this with
four things first grabbing an ancient
battle ax plus plus with a max attack
modifier of 75
then using a triple attack boost to
boost the attack 50 percent
and do 112 damage then using the ancient
armor set's ancient proficiency
which stacks the boost with ancient
weapons by an additional 80 percent
makes it 202 damage and finally by doing
the permanent active hitbox glitch while
riding at high speeds
stores a horseback critical hit modifier
of times 2
overall damage which makes it a whopping
404 damage every time the weapon touches
the enemy
now we're ready to rumble while it's
fairly straightforward to explain that
you just headshot the lino and then
smack them with the axe
this is much harder than it looks
approach too close to the lynel and
lynos become immune to headshots
shoot from too far away and you take too
long to set up the attack
the position of you in relation to the
lynel also matters heavily you have to
turn
your back as fast as possible and if
your swing is too small
the axe won't leave the lynel's hitbox
it won't do any damage
if you swing too wide you will take too
long there's a happy medium to this
technique and it is not easy to do but
if you can navigate around these issues
you've got yourself a technique which is
the fastest way to take down a gold
lynel
without ancient arrows when done
optimally it sets new world records
with the best time so far killing the
poor 7 500 hp lynel in a mere
6 and a half seconds it just risks some
carpal tunnel probably so
be careful if you're gonna go for this
wacky technique at home
hope you enjoyed this explanation of
weird tech being used recently in breath
of the wild
we have more videos explaining new
things that are still being found to
this day
so check out our ongoing breath of the
wild expert series playlist
and for everything else gaming stay
tuned right here on gamespot
you